i want you to just think about you for a  moment i want you to think about your  life  i want you to think about how you're  living versus how you'd really like to  live  you see pay close attention to what  we're doing and you're going to find out  that you can actually create your own  economy  now i learned that many years ago and a  man told me  he said bob if you'll read this book and  do exactly what i tell you  you can have anything you want no i did  not believe that  but after talking to her while i  believed he believed  i was happy he was healthy i was wealthy  i was unhappy i was sick and i was broke  i had no formal education i had no  business experience he said that doesn't  matter bob  what's happened in the past is the past  what happens in the future is based on  the decisions you make